Ron DeSantis
is not doing great right now
he's not doing great against Donald
Trump according to
the latest poll numbers desantis's
announcement did not close the gap
between him and Trump trump still has a
34 point lead in the race
Trump's lead is down a little bit from a
43-point lead
but that constriction of the poll
numbers appears to have happened before
Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis is
presidential announcement
so I think DeSantis is a great Governor
I think he's got a very strong message I
think he's obviously an extremely
intelligent competent guy he's one of
the most conservative presidential
candidates we've seen in my lifetime I'm
not disparaging him
I'm just describing a fact his
announcement didn't work it hasn't moved
the needle the Delta between him and
Trump is just still so massive
there's just some intangible ineffable
je ne sais quoi about the the Trump
campaign that the DeSantis campaign has
not yet figured out how to crack despite
really targeted attacks Trump handing
the country over to fauci really
targeted attacks on some of Trump's
picks and decisions throughout his
administration
still hasn't quite done it
Trump just gave
a response on the campaign trail that I
think helps to get it why
Trump seems Untouchable why he's the
Teflon Don Trump was asked about
wokeness you know wokeness that's that
word on the right we're all just beating
the hell out of wokeness we hate
wokeness and and that's persuading a lot
of moderates and people in the middle
wokeness has got to end
here's Trump's answer on wokeness
it's gone sick and I don't like the term
well because I hear woke woke woke you
know it's like just a term that used
half the people can't even Define it
they don't know what it is
as is often the case well everybody is
zigging Donald Trump is zagging the guy
is contrarian not just with the broader
culture he's contrarian even with the
right the conservative movement the
Republican party in part we should
expect this because the guy didn't spend
his life in the conservative movement of
the Republican Party
and so on this one this is the easiest
softball oh yeah wokeness bad he says I
don't like that term it's kind of a
silly term no one can really Define it
and you know what
he's kind of right
he's kind of right we we use the term as
a shorthand to refer to the extreme
leftists
but a lot of people who regularly use
that term
can't really Define it right now go to
grillblazer.com are you tired of waiting
ages for your grill to heat up well now
you can say goodbye to those tedious
moments of impatiently watching the
charcoal burn and say hello to instant
barbecue Perfection thanks to our new
friends over at Grill Blazer Grill
Blazers Grill guns are designed to do
everything from expertly searing your
Meats to lighting charcoal grills wood
stoves outdoor fireplaces and just about
anything you can think of
that you would need a high power fire
source to solve that problem
[Music]
thank you anything real Blazers offers
two types of Grill guns the grill gun
basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees 30 inch flame for anything you
need a big bad torch to do and the SUV
gun has a shorter Barrel perfect for
professional Culinary Kitchen uses from
gently carbonizing brulay or other
sugars and fruits to rapidly searing
steaks outside on the grill use the
grill gun may result in extreme Grill
Envy from your neighbors and increase
demands for barbecue parties get your
grill gun from Grill Blazers today let
the grilling Adventures begin
grillblazer.com Knowles promo code nulls
for 15 off your order growblazer.com
Knowles promo code nulls for 15 off
right now go to cinch.com use promo code
Knowles you picture that perfect summer
night you imagine the warm breeze on
your face as you Lounge in your favorite
chair outside the grill is sizzling with
those Juicy Burgers the aroma of food is
irresistible your mouth Waters as you
wait for to be cooked to Perfection now
imagine what this perfect summer night
would have looked like if you went to
turn on the grill and your propane tank
was empty
that's where our friends at cinch come
in cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
grill tanks right to your door cinch
delivers on your schedule and requires
no long-term commitment or a
subscription plus delivery is completely
contactless you don't have to wait
around at home track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere go online to
cinch.com or download the Cinch app to
order new customers can get their first
tank exchange for just 10 bucks with
promo code Knowles kwles cinch.com
download the Cinch app promo code nulls
to get your first tank exchange for just
10 bucks limited time offer you must
live within a cinched service area to
redeem it cinch cynch.com offer for
details
you'll notice on my show
I tend to end in my writing and in my
speeches I tend to refer to the libs
I don't refer to the wokies the
wokesters the leftists exclusively
mostly I refer to the libs because
there's a big debate on the right
between is wokism
a betrayal of liberalism or is wokism
The Logical conclusion of liberalism
and not just modern Progressive
liberalism there's another big debate on
the right which is is modern Progressive
leftism
a betrayal of liberalism an illiberal
kind of liberalism or
is modern Progressive leftism The
Logical conclusion of liberalism
in the more libertarian types the more
classical liberal identifying types they
say the former and the conservatives and
the
traditionalists
and the old school right-wingers we say
it's the latter
we say this wokism stuff this was always
going to be the consequence of
liberalism just look at transgenderism
you have the the classical liberals who
say transgenderism it's a betrayal not
only of liberalism but but even of the
gay rights movement it's a betrayal of
all it's a betrayal of feminism but the
conservatives we say
no it's The Logical conclusion of it
because if men and women are pretty much
the same then you're going to get
transgenderism feminism says men and
women are basically the same and so you
get the gay rights movement the gay
rights movement then gives you the
redefinition of marriage redefinition of
marriage then gets you
transgenderism because all of it says
that men and women are pretty much
interchangeable
that's a consequence of liberalism this
flattening liberalism which says that
we're not born into particular roles and
duties some of which are unchosen many
of which are unchosen we have an
obligation to them regardless in a
certain circumstances into communities
that we didn't choose but we have an
obligation to them anyway that's that's
what the conservatives believe the
Liberals just focus on that hyper
individualism you can do whatever you
want just don't hurt anybody or scare
the horses okay well
that's what the Liberals say but that
liberalism is going to inevitably lead
you to wokism and what Trump is saying
here
is that term I don't know you just want
to avoid it you just want to avoid
talking about how liberalism is bad but
I'm not going to and so what does Trump
say he says it's not just that the crazy
Tran stuff is bad
it's that free trade can be bad it's not
just that the crazy trans stuff is bad
it's that the free movement of peoples
across borders can be very bad
it's not just that the trans stuff is
really bad it's that the upending of all
of our Traditions many of which can't be
written down on a napkin in some
rationalist Treatise the upending of our
saluting the flag and having hot dogs on
the fourth of July and just doing things
the way we used to do them because of
sheer tradition and Prejudice Prejudice
in the good sense of that word we just
kind of do it out of a pre-judgment out
of a gut instinct
that that rationalism is bad too
Trump is expressing
a deeply conservative impulse that is
frankly much more in line with what
conservatism
has meant going back to the French
Revolution going back to Edmund Burke up
through much of the American old Riot
before it was taken over by the libs I
think that is part of that Juno sequel I
think that is why a lot of other
candidates even very impressive
candidates like Ron DeSantis haven't
quite caught up with him
yet
okay what whatever you want to say about
Trump the guy his campaign is still on
fire boy what a great clip that was make
sure you subscribe ring that Bell
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time